let's think about what might happen in
the united states if the dollar is
allowed to weaken relative to the dwen
so the most obvious thing is that
chinese imports will become more
expensive
chinese imports
chinese imports will become more
expensive
a less obvious a less obvious effect is
whether that will reduce the demand for
chinese imports or whether that will
have any impact on american inflation
the reason why that's not as clear is
when you go buy when you go buy your
cell phone carrying case at your cell
phone store and you pay and you pay
thirty dollars for it
that thirty dollars is not the cost that
some chinese manufacturer is getting for
it they that that chinese manufacturer
is probably charging on the order of 60
cents or maybe 80 cents or a dollar to
produce that cell phone case the rest of
the money that you're paying is really
going to the retailer it's there to or
the suppliers or is there to essentially
pay for shipping costs from china to the
u.s so this 60 cents which was how much
it cost to make this in china if this
now goes up to if this now goes up to 80
cents or if this goes up to a dollar if
this goes up to a dollar it's not clear
that this price even has to change or
even if it were to change from 30 to 31
dollars it's not clear that that would
affect demand much now the the impact
that this the weakening of the dollar
would have inflate on inflation is the
idea that all imports would become more
expensive so all
all imports potentially and this depends
how other countries react to the
weakening dollar but all imports could
become more expensive and probably the
most important import and once again
this depends on how these currencies
react to some of the oil producing
currencies or oil produ oil producers
actually
peg to the dollar so it might not be as
dramatic as you would think but in
general if you have a weakening dollar
the most important from an american
point of view the most important
important import of all will probably on
the margin become more expensive and
that is
and that is oil we also potentially will
have one less buyer going out there and
motivating or at least directly buying
or motivating other people to go buy us
debt so debt might become more expensive
so debt
could become more expensive in the
united states and when i say debt
becomes expensive that means that
interest rates go up and of course this
is hugely this is hugely dependent on
what the u.s fed does it could step in
it could continue to print more money
and essentially keep debt cheap but it
doesn't it doesn't look as good
optically
now the last and probably the most
important question this is to some
degree you know once again not a not a
clear-cut answer is what happens what
happens to us manufacturing
the argument has been that that
essentially china has been able to uh
produce cheaper than they would have
even naturally been able to produce by
keeping their currency devalued that's
allowed them to essentially steal an
industrial base from the united states
to deplete the industrial base will this
come back will some of this come back
from china or other countries and it is
true a weaker us currency will help the
u.s exports
but what's less clear is whether uh
industries that are are labor defensive
labor dependent and require maybe huge
amounts of skill whether those are going
to come back from asia i suspect like i
said in the video on china that those
are either going to probably stay in
asia or if we had to think about where
they might move if the chinese currency
got stronger i would think that other
parts of asia maybe south asia
or maybe latin america if they can kind
of get their if they could get their act
together those are maybe more natural
places to go because they have the cheap
labor they have lower standards of
living right now and what they would
need to do to compete with china in
particular is essentially have the
infrastructure and the systems and the
efficiency and the scale in place to
compete effectively so these
these are probably the people that china
has to worry about the most if they
devalue their currency
not so much the united states although
it will help u.s manufacturing on the
margin to have a weaker currency this is
salman khan of the khan academy for cnbc